Even before the mastectomy, almost none of my cancer markers came back high.
I ran four of them, 15 CA, 15-3 was a little high.
Once in the normal, the next three times, 19. CEA, we're always doing this.
27-29 was a little high and always normal.
So I just run the CA 27-29.4.
I wouldn't because, you know, cancer markers.
I mean, you know, so cancer markers can be a good way to test progress of your therapy.
But together, it's not perfect because not all cancers will, will spew out the protein.
You know, a person could be having a raging stage 4 cancer.
It's still not spew out any of those proteins and so all their cancer markers are normal.
So, it's not a perfect test.
Just like I said, the little test is going to be perfect.
But, you know, especially if you have basically a full remission diagnosis,
I would still run those, maybe every three to six months,
is because if there is metastasis, the metastatic tumor can be, can release a different cancer marker than the initial tumor.
So you'd hate to miss it.
And cost-wise, I just, I don't think it's that much different to do that panel than it is to do.
One or two of them, so.
I would run, I would run all of them.
I think that's what we've been doing.
Of course, if they're all normal, then you can spread out how often you run them.
So if they're all within your limits, maybe you're only going to just do a scan every six months or something.
And again, just like every other test, you balance it with, with, you know, other signs and symptoms
and other lab tests, too.
So it's, you don't just rely on one test.